he's derek henry he's the titans running
back
joining us on the program after the big
night against the buffalo bills and of
course the stiff arm against josh norman
his college coach coach saban has tested
positive for coronavirus
lot to get to and uh we talked to derek
henry earlier today
and i asked him when will you watch the
game film from the buffalo game
we will watch it today we'll all get
together and watch it today
and um see how good we did and see the
bad things we did
and then see how we can get better okay
but you're gonna know when the stiff arm
against josh norman is coming up
so how long does coach vrabel stay on
that play
i think he'll he'll probably say we all
we all have seen this it's all over the
internet
um and and continue to use it
but next time get more yards out of it
oh
what i i did wonder about that i mean
you did get the stiff arm but then you
went out of bounds
yeah i was looking at him i was so
focused on him
when i falled about by the time i
realized where i was at i was already on
the sidelines
wait so you're looking at josh norman on
the ground and didn't realize you ran
out of bounds
i didn't even realize it i was so skull
caught up in that
looked out i was right by my teammates
on the sideline how do you explain the
last two weeks
trying to prepare not even sure where
you can prepare
how did you prepare for a football game
when you first thought you were facing
the steelers and then it's
you know the buffalo bills yeah it was
uh
i was i was anxious just to you know get
get back on the field get back with my
teammates and
get back to playing ball you know just
uh
working out um staying in shape until we
got
you know the goal to come back in the
building and be able to uh
be together and practice and you know
prepare
for a game and you know a little time we
had we tried to do the best we could to
get some preparation in to go win the
football game and
i think we were not there on tuesday
night you know it showed
you know how much we miss ball love
being together and um you know
playing well and just being a team but
are you practicing in your backyard
like you can't go to the facility so how
do you
what do you do to work out well it's a
park right down the street from where i
live at so i was just
working out running uh every day
just staying in shape wait are there
neighborhood kids or dads down there
working out with you i made sure i went
around
uh the time everybody was in school and
everybody was working so i didn't get
bothered that much i might have seen a
couple of dogs being walked with
not that many people uh what did you
guys learn from last year going to the
afc title game
um that you know as long as we you know
play can play play complete as a team
and
you know believe in one another that we
can go as far as we want to go
but you know the main goal is just
finishing it was good getting there but
you know we want to finish we want to
make it to a super bowl
but we know that you know it starts you
know about the off-season and
through training camp and you know us
just playing complete football as a team
right now to get to that goal i think
you bring up to coach brabel today that
practice is overrated derek
just to say you know coach i don't know
if we really need to work
every day work hard every day
how do you think that'll go over well
i'll tell you this
this today won't be the first time you
heard that because on tuesday night
it was definitely a lot of a lot of
chatter about that
you know during the game after the game
so it was a lot
it was a lot yeah he's uh derek henry
he's got the texans coming up this
weekend
uh have you ever had a conversation with
j.j watt during a game
actually i i haven't um actually haven't
played
you know which is you know not not
knocking him i haven't played him
because you know sometimes
he needs to be hurt or you know things
like that
i think i played against him a few times
you know he's definitely a game wrecker
you know and look forward playing
against him because you know we know
what type of player jj watt is
are you bigger than him
jj what no no
no sir it's close though isn't it
oh let me let me get the the
measurements
on sunday after the game and uh i'll get
back with you
and you know what he loves to be called
justin you got it yeah not jj
just say hey justin how are you i'll say
dan ratchet said
he'd love to call justin word from him
yes and you can do that you have my
permission to say dan patrick said
hey he said to call you justin
uh coach saban when did you find out
about uh him testing positive and can
you imagine what he's gonna be like
at home during a game with you know
playing georgia
yeah um when i found out i was i was
bummed
um but i know you know he's
i know he is going to be itching to be
out there
but i mean with the circumstances you
know just got to do what you got to do
to get healthy and
get back out there um i know i was
talking a lot of
a lot of chatter with my teammates about
this game who went to georgia but
i probably i'll probably quiet down now
to a game day so
well you got steve sarkeesian who's
going to take over but i
what is saban going to be like sitting
there at home
watching the game honestly
that's a good question i'm running the
same thing me and you
are definitely still wanting the same
thing because i it's
so different so i'm sorry i know he's
used to being on the sideline and
we used to see him on the sidelines so
that actually is a good question
and this is a great offense alabama's
got a great offense this might be as
good offense as they've ever had but it
feels like we say that every year
y'all know i mean they score fast
they're explosive you know guys can make
plays at any given moment
so it's going to be an exciting game
would you rather wait
would you rather beat auburn or georgia
both no you don't i said e which one
both or lsu all of them
took them all out but who did you hate
oh uh of course arbor auburn is
is number one that's that's no question
yeah there's no question at all albert's
number one
for sure i went back and looked at your
draft profile
and it told me all the things that you
didn't do well and i
is that why you dropped to the second
round like you were too tall you were
too stiff
you weren't elusive instead of people
focusing on what you did well
they focus on what you don't do well
um i mean yeah i mean that was
that was a lot of it you know during the
when i was coming out
and all i was thinking about is to
control what i can control when i get
here
you know be different um
uh make an impact and you know all the
things said
you know make them regret what they said
yeah and i
do you run with a chip on your shoulder
always
got to you probably got a couple chips
on your shoulders
i probably got about 80 of them on my
shoulder yeah
i remember well uh congrats on the
success against the buffalo bills
and uh have fun against the texans once
again just say hello to justin
watch justin i got it you got it you got
it all right thank you derek
thank you all for having me that's derek
henry titan's running back